[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie as requested
this is the breakdown of the other
Avengers 4 trailer that posted to Reddit
that seems a little bit more legit it
seems much closer to the two minutes
that most of these big Avengers trailers
are so if you're new to the channel
there's a new round of that spider-man
ps4 game giveaway going on all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave an Avengers related comment on the
video and just for reference to there
was a suppose it you know quote-unquote
leaked Avengers for teasers that was
posting all over the internet last night
I'm not omniscient but I am 99.9 percent
certain that it is 100% fake because
while it looks like a very convincing
fake in its shot to look as if somebody
is doing cam footage of an actual
trailer the voice on the trailer
sounds like Arnold Schwarzenegger or
some Swedish person doing Thanos
[Music]
and those two achieve
that's usually a dead giveaway that
something is fan-made so this you know a
couple seconds of gauntlet this is not a
real trailer the reddit one that I'm
talking about is a little bit more legit
so here's how the rundown goes it starts
with a Marvel ten-year anniversary logo
zooms in on the screen but when it
starts rotating around all the colors of
the Infinity stones start flashing all
over it and you get fan OSes voice first
and it says my destiny is not yet
fulfilled there's a shot of Tony on
Titan right after their battles still
looking like he's sitting there all
broken not knowing what's going on
thanassis voiceover continues greater
threats arise to undo the balance
I lost everything to achieve and I will
not be undone there's a shot of Bruce
Banner with Captain America and vision
on a table it fades in and out there's a
shot at Peter Quill's new ship the
Benatar lifting off it fades out we get
Iron Man voice over saying fury was
right he's talking to someone out of
view inside just a normal house on earth
you can't tell who it is
it's implied that that's the scene where
he's telling Aunt May what happened to
Peter that he was turned to dust and
died on Titan he continues speaking he
was right since day one then it fades to
black so they're mixing and matching a
lot of dialogue from different scenes
the scene with him talking to Aunt May
isn't the same scene as where he's
talking about Nick Fury telling him
about all these things that have been
true there's a shot of Iron Man in one
of his new armories looking at three
different suits none of them look like
the new concept art that we've been
seeing so they just could be regular
iterations because the new concept art
is supposed to be marked 85 he grabs one
of his housing units holds it in his
hand and says I'll do whatever it takes
so that never happens again it dips to
black then back to Tony in shield gear
like you see him walking around all
these sets and shield gear he's walking
towards the camera with soldiers behind
him then there's a shot of ant-man
standing in the quantum realm it jumps
to him being surrounded by three
tardigrades
he's running then stops at a green
portal which might be one of the time
vortices that Janet Van Dyne described
the frame fades in and out then you see
Scott Lang standing in a gray shirt
jeans street clothes same clothes that
we've seen him in in the behind the
scenes with Captain America and Black
Widow Scott says I
might have a way to help but we're not
sure who he's talking to because of the
way they cut the dialogue with the
frames there's a shot of an empty throne
room in Wakanda with a bunch of
different shots of Sheree in Baku and
Ocoee the frame dips to black and you
get a voiceover which sounds like it's
coming from a koi a saying this was not
our fight then there's a shot of Captain
America standing with his arms crossed
talking to rody rocket in Thor in a room
that looks like it's still in Wakanda
saying we need to make this right then
it cuts to a shot of banner saying cap
we don't even know where to start
Thanos is gone he won then it cuts the
Thor he says well then we better get to
work they cut to a shot of Captain
Marvel's pager in Tony Stark's hands
there's a really cool CG shot of Rhodey
assembling his war machine gear we
didn't actually get to see him put it on
in the last movie because he has those
special attachments that help him walk
while they're armoring up Thor says are
you ready for this rocket replies well
I'm not it pauses dips to black frame
and you get more rocket saying what more
could I lose you get a shot of Thor in
the Bifrost with war machine and rocket
and then it starts jumping through a
bunch of different really quick scenes
you see the Infinity Gauntlet still
damage being reached for a shot of
nebula than the shot a banner than a
dips to black again Thor says we need an
army to stand against Thanos then
there's a shot of Thanos putting on his
armor again yours is the only one
formidable enough to give us a chance
there's a shot of Thanos wielding that
giant double-edged sword that we've seen
in all the concept art Thor continues
his voice-over saying so I ask of you
and then you get a bunch of various
shots of the other Avengers Black Widow
Iron Man's armor Captain America's new
chainmail chest piece from all the
concept art that we've been seeing
banner putting on that special new Hulk
armor then it fades back to Thor saying
will you help us talking to someone off
camera there's a quick montage of shots
starting with Thanos walking away from a
broken Infinity Gauntlet that he's
thrown to the ground
you get voiceover saying it's been a
while since I've been to earth the music
starts getting louder like it's getting
a little bit more hopeful a little bit
more epic you get a shot of Captain
Marvel's chest panning up to her face on
an alien planet making it seem like Thor
has been trying to recruit her with this
big space army then it cuts to a shot of
her fully powered up with her eyes all
lit up
flying at someone punching it's implied
that she's getting ready to punch Thanos
they flashed the title card then the
classic Avengers theme plays there's a
bit of a post-credits scene where Rhodey
is talking to Rockettes saying I've seen
a lot of crazy things then it pauses his
rocket like looks up at him and says a
talking raccoon definitely tops them all
rocket looks back at the computer
console and says boy if I had a unit
every time I heard that one then you get
a funny Thor reaction saying haha just
laughing at rocket and roadies
interaction and then it cuts that's the
end of the trailer one of the most
important things though is that when
they flashed the title card of the movie
during the trailer there was no actual
title as this person is talking about it
which sounds plausible that they
wouldn't add the actual title of the
movie to the very last second because
there's actually pretty easy to do and
you wouldn't give this to a trailer
house to be cutting this trailer for the
last couple of months and tell them
everything about the movie you really
only give them all the pieces that you
want them to see not necessarily what
the actual plot of the movie is going to
be remember the infinity war trailer
like if Yuri watch it now you get a
sense for what's happening during the
movie but it doesn't really convey what
the actual plot is there wasn't any of
that Vermeer soulstone stuff in there
they actually removed infinity gems from
Santos's gauntlet when he had come back
to Wakanda so keep in mind that all the
scenes happening in the trailer here
aren't linear and not all of them might
wind up in the final version of the
movie but you can kind of see how
they're trying to provide a sense of
continuity with the end of infinity war
where a lot of these people pick up like
Ironman starts when he's still on Titan
so it's gonna explain the time jump how
he gets back to earth how they deal with
the death of everyone going forward
before Scott Lang shows up and before
the Avengers have a plan to fix things
Captain America Shuri Ocoee all the
people that are left alive in Wakanda
pick up in Wakanda trying to figure out
what to do next standing around visions
body most important thing though is the
idea that Thanos's gauntlet just gets
thrown on the ground after everybody's
reaching for it as if he's trying to
keep people from taking it but then
throws it on the ground because he
doesn't need it anymore
that very clearly has something to do
with the greater threat rising to undo
the balance that he created there was
the description of the Avengers new
armor a little while ago that we got the
teased and even greater threat than
Thanos we still don't know what that is
we
still don't have confirmation on what
the title is but once we find out what
the title is it'll be a little bit
easier to figure that out but when
you're thinking about other big villains
that could be worse than Thea knows just
think about the quantum realm and how
the Avengers are gonna try and use it to
fix things there's already so many
characters and so much plot to get
through so many arcs to close that would
be kind of weird if they introduced a
brand new big villain that we haven't
met before that you don't have any real
emotional connection to so unless
they're reaching for a really deep cut
like a villain from a previous movie
becoming a much bigger deal it might be
the way that the Avengers fix things
that leads to that greater threat like
they might be the cause of the big thing
that Thanos is talking about the person
that posted this to reddit is also the
same person that was quoting the trailer
date as being sometime late November
early December I've already talked about
that one of my previous videos because
it's around the same time they dropped
the first infinity war trailer so just
let me know in the comments what you
think about this version of the trailer
because it does sound a little bit
closer to two minutes in the way they
cut that first infinity war trailer with
all the dips to black and all the
voiceover over mismatching scenes it
sounds a lot more like something that
Marvel would do to try and mislead you
so that you don't actually find out what
the real plot of the movie is I've got a
bunch of other Marvel and DC videos that
I'm working on so I'll try to get
through those as fast as possible leave
your requests in the comments below I'll
name a giveaway winner when I post new
Marvel click here for that new
spider-man far from home teaser and
click here to watch Tom Hiddleston talk
all about Loki and Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]